greetings apiece welcome to the Dean
show the show where you get the facts
not fiction about the fastest growing
way of life in the world yet most
misunderstood and we have another one of
those people have seen through all the
hype the false propaganda he's accepted
his way of life Dexter is with me on
daddy's show to tell us his story when
we come back don't go anywhere
this is the
this is the video this is the thesis 15
June you know this is the thing he's
been a huge topical when I cancel on
rock but Allah most of our Dexter how
you doing I'm good a humdinger brother
hamdulillah so what is it was Dexter
prior to being Mustafa that's correct
yes why did you change your name well
Courtney is Lama I wanted a good name so
the name matures was one of the best
names is one of the names of our beloved
prophet muhammad's allah wa sallam he
was called many names ahmed but also
mustafa so in islam mustafa means the
chosen one mm-hmm so i believe that
allah chose me to become a muslim yeah
so i named myself after that but you
were formerly a former baptist yes tell
us a little bit about this well former
Baptist you know growing up
african-american community born here in
America and through the years my parents
just brought me up in the church so it
wasn't my choice it was more of a family
upbringing but you know even in my early
years they have questions you know who
do you pray to this time because in
Christianity is you have three you have
the Holy Ghost
you have ISA Jesus and you have God but
you know the question will always in my
mind who do you pray to so hum daily
love over the years you know with the
growing age and a growing mind you come
to think for yourself and extra
questions so years ago that the seat
Allah Planet that seat in my head to
start questioning my belief as a
Christian so as the years progressed I
I start to read had opportunity to work
with Muslims early in my age and then
the hamdulillah you know they the CD can
be game became to grow in my heart tell
us a little bit about to see the first
initial seed the first encounter that
you had with someone cuz most people you
know they did a poll ABC did a poll and
now it's gotten that it went from in
2001 I believe it was like something
about 49 or 50 percent most people
didn't know anything about Islam and now
and had actually a bad image most of
them because now they haven't had
exposure like you did to Muslims I think
it's even dropped to 27 percent now so
at that time you know we can see you
didn't obviously have any exposure what
was it like now that you had this
exposure with first time with the Muslim
and what was your perception of Islam
before them well my perception of Islam
growing up again in african-american
community it was always you know you get
beats and bits and pieces of Islam is
it's it's a sect as the religion is not
valid they don't believe in God so you
know even in the secular education the
Islam wasn't talked about in school very
much so hamdulillah you know my first
experience was a Muslim members
believers 18 19 years old I started
managing early in my in my in my age and
I remember it was when one brother name
was Elijah and this brother was one of
the most memorable people I've met my
life quiet calm well temper were
respected and I couldn't but ax him we
know brother why do you dress this way
and Elijah why do you speak this way
he's and a Muslim so he started to tell
me a little bit about you know what what
a Muslim is and what Islam is so as the
years passed I lost connection with his
brother but then a hum date Allah maybe
ten years later I came across more
Muslims who work for me over the years
and I learned about the fasting and you
know who Allah was it was the same God
that we all worship and you know
took it from there was this complete
opposite I mean did you this was back in
what year was this this is maybe 1994 so
this before 9/11 oh yes
so now 9/11 happens where you have
Muslim so you're Muslim at that time I
would not a Muslim after 9/11 you also
use up there some after nine less after
9/11 yeah okay what were your thoughts
after you see your research in your
learning Islam and then you have
something like this link people are
trying to link this to Islam well I
think life is always fact-based and
given a point that you know first when
you see the media of course you you
start to believe what the media puts on
at first most people do but as the facts
unfolded and you start to learn what may
happen what may not have happened you're
free to make your own opinion but when
it comes to embracing Islam once ayah
breaks the Islam I knew without a doubt
that Islam preaches peace even though
there are some misguided people in Islam
who do the opposite of it I knew in my
heart that Islam is a religion of peace
well what do you think when you have you
know many people out there they'll say
yeah these Muslims say that islam
teaches that it's about promotes peace
but they got the peace messed up which
means pieces well I'll say peace over
here a piece over there it's the human
nature unfortunately and I believe may
it may Allah guide these brothers and
sisters to the to the straight truth and
the right path I mean but you know
without a doubt if you look at the
history of Islam Islam was preached by
the by the character of the Muslim it
wasn't spread by the sword that's a fact
that's the fact and people are coming to
get facts you're not fiction so that's
something that people can verify people
can verify they don't pick up a book
read about it don't take my word you can
find this out for yourself yeah
definitely definitely so tell us more
now about your journey so you end up
meeting a Muslim and what was the
deciding factor that had you actually
accepted the decided factors when I when
I started asking my questions that
always had for myself you know how come
God if God was one how come we
have to you know believe in three and
who has the final say so because in
anything there has to be one creator who
has the final say so so I started to
read the book sacks you know where can I
find out more about Islam what it
preaches what it is
so a brother guided me to Islamic
bookstore North Side of Chicago so I
start to remember spending countless
hours on weekends on my days off
research in Islam and what it is and
hamdulillah I was convinced there only
has to be one God the one who created
the heavens on earth without any help
without any rest
so that bad fact was the planet in my
heart and a Hum Dil up I decided to set
this lump as my faith we're gonna be
right back to get more of your story on
the Deen show with Mustafa formerly
known as Dexter here on the Deen show
don't go anywhere she had often
mistranslated as holy war the word jihad
means to struggle Islam does not preach
violence it does not preach vicious holy
war it certainly does not condone terror
and suicide bombing Islam preaches
compassion tolerance and justice find
the truth about Islam call toll-free 877
why Islam back here on the Deen show
with my brother Dexter formerly known as
Dexter Mustafa a former Baptist and now
you're actually a community peace
activist yes tell us about this
alhamdulillah provided me with the
opportunity to tell others about you
know my faith and and what it is and
what it is not
so I regularly meet meet non-muslims
every Friday and here in the Chicago at
the Muslim community center and we bring
we bring in students and we bring in
anyone who wants to know the ins and out
about Islam so I really tell them what
Islam is and what it's not there's a lot
of controversies controversies and
misconceptions about Islam so now I have
the opportunity to tell people exactly
what Islam is tell us some of the major
misconceptions went because you have a
lot of experience now in this out doing
is outreach to the not-yet Muslims out
there and they come
and they asked sometimes really tough
questions some people might be bitter
about some things they heard on fox news
and now they come in and you're speaking
to them what are few of the really
controversial things that people bring
up the the biggest controversy is other
killings how come you know there are
many so so quote-unquote senseless
killing by Muslims so I tell the people
this is a proof this is a fact you can
research it in our faith that a killing
is a great sin
killing a innocent person is a great sin
in our religion we say Allah says spanha
what Allah says that if you kill an
innocent person is like killing all of
mankind so as a Muslim if you accept
that you know that there's something
you're not supposed to do but again
people they take passages from the Quran
and they misinterpret and they're there
they're there they're led astray on the
wrong path yeah tell us now for these
groups that come in have you actually
had some people you know come back
accept Islam you know because we know
Islam is simple as rational and makes
sense and it's the fastest growing
religion in the world today you know
it's it's La Mesa is I always say a
thinking person religion also because
everything is fact-based
we have authentic chains of
communication where people can actually
look up for themselves to see the
authenticity of things so a lot of the
college students are thinkers and a lot
of them ask questions they actually
extra translated copy of the crime and
hamdulillah some people actually came
back and accepted the faith well now
let's go back to when you accepted Islam
what did you have to do to become a
Muslim well that well that there's a
open testimony it's called an Islam is
called the Shahada so you first you have
to have belief in your heart and the
Shahada is when you announce that belief
outwardly in front of people so I
remember coming to the Masjid and
Spaniel I was nervous so I remember that
night I came after Maghrib and it was a
brother who walked outside as I was
coming in and he used to be one of my
employees and he's like Dexter what are
you doing here come to take my Shahada
hello I'm doing a lot
come on in so he brought me into
everybody everybody was happy to meet me
so I took my Shahada in front of
everybody so at that point I shadow a la
ilaha illallah allahu wa ashadu allah
and the [ __ ] after who ever saw
allah open testimony in front of
everybody so at that point I had entered
Islam mmm beautiful that I'd like to
compare that make a contrast that if you
were living during the time of Jesus you
would say Allah Muhammad la la la la
Issa Rasool Allah there's no deity
worthy of worship except the Creator and
Jesus is the master if you're living
during the time of Jesus if you're
limited during the time of Moses or
Abraham you'll pronounce that I'm not
going to worship anything but the
Creator and I'm going to follow that
messenger at that time the last
messenger today you said Mohammad Rasool
Allah Muhammad is the last and final
messenger preaching the same message as
Jesus and all the other messengers and
now how do you feel it's been how many
years now it's been seven years how is
your community your family how are they
taking this news a hundred Allah my
family has you know they've been some
supportive but I hummed along our way we
grow up and we keep peaceful relations
with our family because as in Islam we
can't break the relations so we have to
keep it the peaceful family relations so
alhamdulillah have been married my wife
is Muslim so alhamdulillah think things
that are good a happy home how do you
feel when you see your this way of life
maligned when you maybe you turn on Fox
News and there's hysteria created around
Islam you know III don't buy into a lot
of the media again growing and growing
up in America not the same media is bad
but some media is misleading so you know
I believe that a person should research
and you make you an opinion about things
so quite naturally in every religion
there's people who are misguided they
follow their own desires and hearts and
feelings but Islam Allah spend a dollar
he sent down the Quran clearly and
verbatim whatever a lot of commands that
you which you should do it's not about
how I feel about something it's what you
should do so understand people follow
their own thought
and desires but that's not the way it's
supposed to go in Islam before we go to
break what would you do and say to let's
say a politician or somebody you know
you had some recently where a politician
was saying basically making Islam to be
out the enemy so what would you say now
if you had an opportunity to talk to one
of these politicians what would you tell
them about now their statements because
they came in would you invite them to
come to the mosque and what would you
say to someone like that who try to make
your religion out to be a religion of
terror
I would have been whoever has any
questions about Islam that's it Dustin
Ellen let's have a dialogue let's talk
about it at the same time the Quran and
Sunnah is there read for yourself our
Quran since the time it was revealed
from Allah to Gabriel a salam to prophet
mohammed salah solemn it hasn't been
changed so I would tell that politician
to read for yourself and compare to what
you see from people to what the religion
says is quite clear we're going to take
a break and we right back to wrap up
Dexter most of a story here on Deen show
don't go anywhere
be worship Jesus no you don't worship
Jesus worship the call of Jesus you are
you worship the God of Jesus the one who
Jesus fell on his face and prayed to
that's when we worship now do we only
believe in Mohammed no we believe in all
the prophets - started when the first
man created
I'm Adam to a brown look her son Jacob
and the tribe Moses King Jesus so the
last pop was only hummus or some peace
be upon them so we believe in all those
messages you mentioned who you mentioned
you know and there's many more
so we believe in out all of them yes all
the ones that are mentioned in the Quran
and other than the yeah awesome day you
know you don't worship tell me what you
worship Allah who's a crater but it's
part of the belief to believe in these
messages yes your name like Jesus want
to leave them done we don't worship them
don't worship them yes back here on the
Dean show and we're getting Dexter's
story change the name to Mustafa really
a wonderful name tell us now we know
that it's very easy to comprehend Islam
yes you read the evidence is there it's
not calling you to blind faith
everything is there laid out it's a
blueprint how to live your life the
meaning of light the purpose of life
based on proof and evidence but now it
takes some struggle it you got a
commitment you guys start praying five
times a day fasting establishing the
five pillars being kind being charitable
all these things that maybe people
weren't doing before now you got to live
by this how's that been well Islam is a
take Islam day by day we we have to pray
five times a day we have to give our
rights to everybody to have true tongue
which means doesn't lie give charity so
you really have to work at this it's not
you you accept Islam and everything is
easy for you
I believe Allah says in the Quran just
be saying you just because you say you
believe doesn't mean you won't be tested
that's your inertia what this means is
that Islam is a struggle and we have to
we have to put forth effort to stay upon
the right path on that faith so Islam
for me is day by day prep by prayer and
we try to do the best we can this Muslim
dexstar tell us now in contrast to
Christianity the former religion you
were part of when you make a mistake now
you got to go through Jesus for instance
this mighty messenger that no Muslim is
a Muslim obviously if we don't love and
revere Jesus but we don't take him as
God's Son of God he's a messenger God is
God how did you repent before and how do
you if you make a mistake now what do
you do
Pierson's well you in Christianity you
reprinted you repented in the name of
Jesus to God and being a formal
Christian that was always my struggle
why would you have to go through
somebody to talk to God but Islam makes
it clear you go right to Allah to God
and so the connect between the creator
and the creation is uninterrupted so you
repent directly to God directly to God
now we use these interchangeably you say
Allah God this is God God Allah is the
same God
lah who was from Adam alayhi Salam Adam
to me Adam Eve as people say or Moses or
Ibrahim Abraham to ISA Jesus now we have
Mohamed Salah some same guy did this fit
does this make sense that now just take
you out of a land of confusion to Allah
it made it real it made everything clear
when you understand that the guy who
created Adam and Eve and Abraham and
Jesus and Muhammad SAW Allah Allah is
the same God it makes everything
unquestioning to be clear beautiful now
before we leave you're also you've
actually taken it to another level you
we've talked about you being a peace
activist calling Vedic people peace
calling people to peace you know helping
in the outreach of the to the community
- not yet Muslims what do you have to
say to all those are viewing and they're
kind of stuck in the same similar
position that they're confused about
this Trinity about God but they hear a
lot of negative things being associated
with Islam what would you say to them I
tell people to rush to hurry up to
search out the truth because the reality
about life is only temporary so what we
have time we should make our own mind up
with facts and Islam is a fact-based
religion it dates back to the first
messenger the first creation which is
Adam and the last Ummah the last a
Direct Connect book from Allah from God
to mankind was the crime so we should
see as a human what was the last thing
that God had to say to us directly so I
would rush I encourage everybody to rush
to find the truth for themselves
that's what the intelligent minds should
do right that's what the intelligent
mind should do and when you pray pray
right to God no middleman no concessions
just right from you to your Creator
beautiful advice thank you so much for
being with us we started with peace and
we end with peace peace be with you
Salaam alaikum alaikum Salaam and thank
you for tuning in like I said in the
beginning this shows about facts not
fiction people who have shared their
life stories with us who have come from
other religions and why would they come
to this religion and why would it be the
fastest growing religion in the world
with the whole world up against it if it
was a religion a way of life of terror a
barbaric religion Islam is definitely a
way of life that brings peace and
contentment to your soul to your heart
and connects you with the one who
created the heart and I can sit here and
talk it till I'm blue in the face but
you if you're sincere and you want to
know the truth you're going to be the
one who's going to have to search it out
who's going to have to sincerely ask the
one who created creation the one creator
to guide you to it and continue to come
back here every week to the Deen show
and I'm sure if you're sincere and you
wanted to know the truth this made sense
to you but if you're somebody who just
has this prejudice this racism in the
heart who just angry with life anyway I
don't know how much is this going to
help but you know what there's hope for
you too so continue to tune it follow us
on the Facebook on the Twitter subscribe
to us here at the Deen show on our
YouTube page and continue to support the
program we'll see you next time until
then peace be unto you